[Music]
Hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with his brief information for today, Tuesday
, April 27. If you are looking for jobs nearby, he
is organizing a job fair. Today
the resort is looking to hire lifeguards,
waitress, security room service,
among other positions,
this event will be open
starting  at 9 in the morning at
the kolding gay casino ballet the
interviews will take place right there
however you must fill out the
online application prior to presenting yourself
that is not the whole stadium ali well
it is also hiring for
the rider games the team is looking for  2,200
part-time workers for
local games in different positions
for more information visit our
page and instraw dotcom diagonal in
Spanish
if you want to get the vaccine today the
mexican consulate in las vegas will have
a clinic starting at 8
in the morning the consulate  it is located at
823 shakespeare and for more details
visit our page of equis out
pun  tocom diagonal en español and now
we move on to the weather forecast
we will have some north
valley winds with some clouds the high for
today will be close to 70 degrees but
don't be discouraged the heat will be back for the
rest of the week the temperatures
will be hitting record highs  for
Friday and Saturday of this week
have a nice Tuesday 8 this light minil
this was your brief information for them
now in Spanish
[Music]